it's the end of an era right talk to me
first about what it's like kind of
saying goodbye to a character or at
least for this moment in time it's like
it's so crazy to be saying goodbye to
these movies that have just changed my
life it's emotional it's sad it's happy
it's everything like i can't believe
it's over and i can't believe that
happened
[Music]
so lee and rachel did end up getting
back together again it turns out that
sometimes people do find their way back
to each other we see this amazing time
jump in the end of the movie is that is
is it what you expected is it where you
thought the characters would be at that
point
yes i think that these movies wrapped up
so perfectly we all found our way back
to a very familiar place
oh my god
no way and suddenly there was
they're still doing this
[Applause]
i credit so much to vince marcelo our
writer director who like
just
hit it out of the park because it's so
hard we have a third movie you know it's
hard because you want to give the fans
what they want without
like
just closing the book you want to give
it a little spice little flavor a little
like will you paint it so um i think we
had so much fun just creating an ending
for these characters and also hoping
that our fans can kind of guess where
things go later
speaking of later if it was your
decision to make to bring back this
character at some point down the line
whenever what era of time in her life do
you think would be most interesting to
explore
i want to see l in the 40s i want to see
what she's up to i want to see what
she's like because she's fun she's cool
i think she'll always be fun and cool
and i just want to see if we're right
when i'm in my 40s when l's in her 40s
when we are in our faces yeah i wonder
is it do we see l with kids where did we
see l with at that point for sure right
i think she's i mean i personally want
kids so i think l has kid i think that
her and these kids are best friends
that's what i'm thinking let's talk a
little bit about the relationship in the
movie
i think that possibly maybe i'm falling
for you
in your heart of hearts does it continue
forever is it happily ever after from
here on out i don't know i mean that's
the thing i don't want to put my
view on it too heavily because i want
everyone to be able to paint their own
picture i think that
these characters and l and noah have
gone through so much and
they always have this flutter in their
heart for each other and regardless of
what the ending is or maybe or what
could be
i i never think they'll lose that if
they don't or if they do wind up
together what's been the best part for
you what's been your favorite thing
about working on this series i think
that my favorite thing about i mean it's
hard to narrow down i just i have made
so many wonderful friends
being these movies
cast the crew but also just going on
this journey we had no idea what a
success system would be we had no idea
the reach we would have and the global
reach that we've had with these movies
blows my mind and so knowing that these
movies are just as special to so many
people as they are to me
it's just it's like nothing feels better
than that and you work so hard on
something and you hope that people love
it and that people watch it and when
they do you're like yes so that's a
really good feeling if you could send
the fans off with something what do you
think it is they what's the message what
do you think they take away from this
film
i hope they i mean i hope they take away
of course the messages of you know
taking time to make decisions for
yourself and not just
making decisions for other people but
also i really hope they've just enjoyed
laughing with us i mean we've laughed so
much while making these movies we've had
so much fun making them doing them
watching them
and i've had some of the best
memories of my life on these sets and i
hope that people feel that and they
enjoyed it as much as i i love making it
for them
you